I reject nation I'm Greg a yeah we're
filming Hungary Czech nation I'm Greg
Alva Deming here with us today
Paula Deming actually covers Doctor Who
reactions over there on the fan Theory
TV YouTube channel you guys should go
check that out also she does a twitch
and YouTube gaming stream it of him
self-proclaimed nerd right here hey have
you heard of Bohemian Rhapsody this is
how we talk off camera answer now
comment below well you said you saw the
trailer and the beaters but there's this
feature at how called becoming Freddie
which I'm excited to see because that's
the big appeal of this movie is Rami
Malek mr. robot right that's the one
yeah so he was in a video game that I
started playing that I haven't felt
called until dawn just like a horror
film teen flick video game yeah let's
get hitting this ball let's do it
I've heard this song think I know this
song about wrong can you see what you
could be kind of a weird-looking dude to
be honest
one of the first times I heard about
this was the producer is calling me on
the phone and asking if I would come to
Los Angeles American the mustache
considering me for this role of Freddie
Mercury was it really helps his face I
think actually this is Freddie and he
wasn't just acting it was something that
came naturally that's cool
are you set out to play Freddie Mercury
you think how am I ever going to fill
this responsibility I was very eager to
take the microphone
[Music]
Wow Ronnie's worked so hard any given
moment he's always practicing Freddie
smooth but also he's found a real
humanity to this character 50 hours of
costume fittings oh my goodness me a
dress as Freddie does it makes every day
feel like it's gonna be a good time like
body image issues while he was shopping
all these just one of the best
performances I've seen for a very very
long time
[Music]
Wow after watching that there's one
thing this movie has a shirt because
from seeing the trailers I've had only
one concern and this might seem like a
silly concern but I think it's kind of a
leak I see the trailers it's always
these like epic concert shots and so
much music overlapping which gets me
excited cuz I grew up on Queen I really
love Queen Freddie Mercury I consider
the best vocalists of all time I'm
really looking forward to this but then
when I watched the trailers I kind of
sit back and go through a real plot here
or it's like a bunch of cool concerts
yeah and I know there was like oh this
whole thing is Bryan Singer directed
this movie and that has a really big
Fronter rightfully so and there was a
whole thing where like he didn't even
like finish some of the movie or
whatever and the cinematographer had to
do it was like looking at the footage
here I'm like well the movie looks great
though you know in that department but
if there's one thing for sure that will
be great from this movie arguably is the
most important thing it's gonna be rad
me Mouse performance as Freddie Mercury
that's gonna be perfect just thinking
about it as
a performer if there was like fear in
him and like taking on this role to take
on such a icon an iconic character such
specific mannerisms and things about him
whether or not he felt like a lot of
pressure of you was like hesitate or if
he was just like I can do this I'm
diving right in I got this well it seems
to me that the best actors take on roles
that they truly feel challenged to role
roles act terrified and there was that
part in the beginning where he's talking
about how he's gonna fill these shoes
and I like the responsibility factor
that he has here when you have that that
weight on your shoulders as originally
it was Sacha Baron Cohen who was cast he
left the project and now Sasha Greco
probably did a good job but it would
have been a little distracting it was
Sasha Biko from watching the trailer
footage I was like oh he's actually
British I was like maybe he's doing
something a little different with his
voice but that's just too good there's
no way this guy's American didn't even
like cross my mind so hearing him here
I'm like oh [ __ ] this dude's American
yeah and I love that part about how he
himself said it that he made the choice
to not have a choreographer chosen I
want to have an actor really talking he
wasn't all like hey I did this I created
this character buy into me and my hype
and whatever like he was like look
someone help me with this yeah people
don't often acknowledge that he's like
Sherman came in and helped me really get
into this character and what a
fascinating job to have yeah who's a
movement coach she studied like probably
all of Freddie Mercury stuff and then
took that too
Rami they worked on it together really
like the little things and that's what's
gonna make this character feel real
because they got those little things
that attention to detail that made me
really excited yeah because they were
not just talking about obviously the the
signature moves that real Freddie
Mercury does on stage the way he handles
were throwing the mic and walks across
the stage there's like all those cool
dance moves it's like the little things
though of how he looks up how he uses
his eyes those big attention to details
make the biggest difference in any
performance you do and I think
especially if you're doing a biopic role
an actor has to really know the
physicality and then also can't just
make it but has to internalize all this
so feel yeah that's really fascinating
that he knew he was working on a court
where the choreographer and then he made
the choice I never heard of that of
going oh no I need someone was different
even movement coach I've never heard of
an actor doing that before I've heard of
actors taking on movement coaches but
never making this like conscious choices
like you really took on the
responsibility of like how do I create
this role in the best I sort of
mentioned this before he's talking about
like all of his costumes where for me
I'd be like I think he's naturally
skinny okay anytime I've seen this guy
anywhere and anything him I was like
he's a really skinny dude so just seems
like it worked in his favor I think that
barber looked at a weird that might have
been around the time when Freddie
Mercury started getting he'll yes you're
probably right I felt bad immediately
after I said it cuz then I was like oh I
bet that's a clip of him being like
about how he looks weird I'm innocent so
both all those people who judge you made
it to this part of the video before
clicking off here just in general helps
helps the whole structure of his day he
should always have the Freddie Mercury
mustache yeah listen guys before I wrap
this up I wanted to give a page from the
day shout-out to a woman named Victoria
Huntley who lives all the way in the UK
and she actually sent me photos of her
and her hubby named Ricky and man are
they a sexy-looking couple it's rare I
see a married couple other than Paul
haven't seen her husband but I'm
assuming he's sexy he's good he's no
he's no Ricky in my mind because your
hobby hasn't pledged to our patreon page
so that's why I think Victoria's hubby
is so much sexier so if you want to get
sexy in my eyes become a pager become a
patreon Oh Greg no Victoria you're very
sweet and yeah you're always messaging
me always getting little catch ups on
your life and
learning a little bit about you each and
every day so I'm so happy for all the
support you've shown us and I hope that
you and Ricky have a beautiful child one
day who doesn't murder you when he grows
up I thought you were like making their
pregnancy announcement for them right
now you might not know this Victoria
you're preggers it's cool normally I
guess in the channel they can't help out
with the shoutouts as they don't know
who I'm talking to but you have an
improv skill about chapala who what
where yes and yes and establish your
characters and location with improvising
about improv those are the best kind of
improv shows listen guys subscribe to
the reel rejects yeah Paula fan Theory
TV if you want to watch along with
Doctor Who with her also her twitch
YouTube Paula Deming you know Instagram
and Twitter she exists there as well all
new description box check out our
patreon there's a lot of goodies over
there we have TV show reactions of Q&A
is with John Ellis recovers music videos
so see ya